so what I want to do here is have a
quick discussion about Jessica Cruz one
of two characters who are starring in
the ongoing DC rebirth Green Lantern
series and what I'm hoping is that at
the end of this video you'll have a
solid understanding of her character as
well as why she's proven to be such an
important and popular character in DC
Comics
so Jessica Cruz was created by writer
Geoff Johns and artist Doug mink as the
final part of the Green Lantern series
leading in to rebirth but to also
bolster the roster of the existing
earth-based team referencing my video on
Hal Jordan explained following his
introduction into DC Comics the Green
Lantern line had experienced a litany of
cancellations and reboots prior to Geoff
Johns taking over the concept in 2004
after which the series saw a massive
upheaval including the introductions of
new cores a retelling of the universes
origin as well as expansions on the
Lantern mythos and the timeline of its
continuity as a result where readers
previously consider the Lantern title to
be lackluster under John's the series
experienced a massive amount of success
with many considering it to be the
pinnacle of his work appearing for the
first time and Green Lantern issue
number 20 in July of 2013
Jessica Cruz is a Latin American woman
who was sought out by the Ring of Illume
a curse power ring inhabited by the evil
spirit of ol Foom who draws strength
from the where's fear while
simultaneously killing them but this bit
of information is actually a source of
confusion to sidetrack here within the
Green Lantern mythos and as part of
Geoff Johns Reformation both whom served
as the basis behind the Third Army story
arc and the main antagonist and the
wrath of the first Lantern story arc and
that during the early days of the
universe's history the extra dimensional
time traveler volthoom had encountered
the Owens and tutored them in the ways
of the emotional spectrum as a result he
was offered the position as the Owens
first Lantern after which his hubris
took control sending him into a state of
madness with the intention of using the
emotional spectrum to conquer all of
reality where he was sealed away by the
Owens and remained hidden from the
universe for billions of years during
the Third Army and wrath of the first
Lantern events he had emerged from
stasis seeking to draw on the full
emotional spectrum as a means to remake
reality where his defeat came at the
hands of
Lantern Corps and the emotional spectrum
uniting against him confusion between
the Ring of Illume and Vulcan himself
comes in a lack of reconciliation what I
mean here is that during the events of
forever evil where the evil version of
the Justice League from earth 3 invaded
the main DC continuity the crime
syndicates version of Green Lantern was
named power ring and used the ring of
Illume as a source of energy the problem
we face here is that as far as I can
tell DC has never reconciled the two
leaving us as fans to believe that the
spirit of all Foom within the power ring
was an entirely different being from the
version who appeared during the Third
Army and wrath of the first Lantern that
said with the standard power of the
Green Lantern's hails from their ability
to draw strength from their own
willpower as a means to conquer their
fears and approach various situations
with the utmost tenacity the ring of
Illume exists in the opposite form and
that like the yellow ring of fear the
ring of volthoom
draws on the fear of its user but takes
it a step further by killing them over
time now in terms of Jessica Cruz
because the ring of volthoom seeks out
those who experience extreme fear
jessica was actually a perfect host
winding the clock back to Justice League
issue number 32 Geoff Johns established
that Jessica had gone hunting with her
friends and accidentally came across a
group of men who were burying a dead
body looking to ensure that there were
no witnesses to their crime the men
killed all of Jessica's friends while
Jessica herself managed to escape
following her ordeal she spent the next
four years locked away in her room
suffering from extreme agoraphobia and
PTSD under the fear that her friends
killers were still looking for her at
the same time with forever evil seeing
the death of power ring as part of the
crime syndicate the ring of ol Foom
sought out his next host eventually
settling on Jessica owing to her extreme
fear initiative refusing and even going
so far as to shoot the ring
Jessica's efforts were in vain and at
the ring forced itself upon her and down
Jessica with all disabilities now enter
early appearances unlike the Green
Lantern's Jessica was not in control of
the ring on her finger using her body
the ring attacked a group of rescue
workers attracting the attention of both
the Justice League and the Doom Patrol
while the Doom Patrol was able to reach
Jessica first by this point in time
Jessica's perception has been altered to
believe that volthoom power over her is
too strong and her fear is too great
tying the role of Jessica into DC's
overarching darkside war VIN and the
eventual launch of rebirth under Jeff
Jones he was revealed that the ring
actually has no power over Jessica if
she's not afraid of it a belief which
was confirmed by Batman who Dee powered
the ring by coaxing Jessica into being
brave and standing up for herself
following this both Batman and Barry
Allen continue to try to help her fight
the Rings influence reminding Jessica
that she has power over her fears and by
extension power over the ring eventually
allowing her to gain control of herself
sending volthoom into a state of
dormancy now because Jessica remained in
this kind of no-man's land of DC Comics
and that earth already had several Green
Lantern's and the reception to her
character was lukewarm for Jessica used
the powers of the ring for good and even
became a member of the Justice League
suspense on the nature of her character
was maintained by having Jessica walk a
knife's edge with the possibility
constantly lingering in the background
that she may fall again eventually
succumbing to both film's influence
while these various trials and
tribulations came in her anxiety of
being around crowds of people as well as
volthoom whispering to her from the ring
Batman and the other members of the
Justice League sought to give her a
variety of tests and challenges to help
Jessica prove to herself that she was
stronger than the ring to this end her
defining moment came during the events
of Darkseid war proper when Grail the
daughter of Darkseid travelled to earth
with the intention of taking the ring of
a Finn for herself and using it to bring
anti-monitor to that reality using
Darkseid war as a means to wrap up all
new sins following the various members
of the league being transformed into
gods with Barry Allen and the black
racer merging into a singular entity
which maintained the black racers role
as an aspect of the entity death during
the final battle Grail summoned the
black racer and separated it from Barry
Allen leading to the black racer
pursuing Barry under the idea that the
entity requires a soul in order to
return to its original state using this
to her advantage
Jessica Crews alongside cyborg allowed
volthoom to take over Jessica's body in
its entirety while simultaneously
jumping between Barry and the black
racer killing Jessica in the process and
returning to its dimension the story
actually revealed that the black racer
did not kill Jessica and instead took
the spirit of voloom destroying the
power ring and leaving Jessica free of
the spirit
trol and so spending the events into the
conclusion of darkside war and going
into DC rebirth Hal Jordan had inducted
Jessica into the Green Lantern Corps
proper under the auspices that her
bravery and willpower allowed her to
overcome her fear with that being said
we're going to bring this video to an
end and let me know how you guys feel
about Jessica Cruz I'm kind of curious
now we'll catch you all later peace